cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I know that uh Nancy Pelosi
said she's a reptilian this week let's
see if you did type it in type it in
last week she said I'm cold blooded and
I'm reptilian
I really thinks he's a freaking reptile
but something is weird I mean the point
that he's making is the Gnostic religion
has been around since before like
Christianity and before I can't Google
it because it says it looks like the
results below are changing quickly check
the source is it a trusted topic she
said it on uh MSNBC I forget whose show
she was on she just said it if you type
in type it on Twitter and Pelosi wrote
because he's probably gonna give you a
bunch of fake stuff but she just said it
this week and type in Pelosi Twitter or
Pelosi reptilian but no I do think it's
demonic or satanic I know that sounds
weird but there's something to it and
whether you believe in it or not like
Phil said here we go here we go let's
play it Nancy Nancy Pelosi she's really
really committed to that it's really sad
no I'm not a poor baby I'm more
reptilian cold blooded and Cohen will
win the election uh we're gonna take a
short break I want to talk to you what
was that
CIA agent we got to take a break
calm down come on what is she referring
to let me play
I think Helen will win the election what
is she saying please go in and win the
election no I'm not a poor baby I'm more
reptilian cold-blooded and go in will
win the election uh we're gonna take a
short break I want to talk to you more
about President
I guess it's impossible to know what
what with only 13 seconds what is she
referring to in the context of being
reptilian in cold blooded she's saying
she's like ruthless in law yeah like
she's gonna go get it like a lizard and
probably she saw the memes of like the
her looking like a lizard Meme and stuff
I'm not as confident in that part
I don't think she saw the meme so did we
ever figure out if her husband is a
homosexual did we ever figure that out
that's still undeterminate and that's
the cool fears yeah yeah
I wish that I wish it was more context
so I could understand why she's saying
this I'm assuming she's saying like I'm
ruthless yes that was what I got out of
it but like we don't know
let's try it again uh you know of course
you're just gonna say that but poor baby
yeah she's really really committed
no I'm not a poor baby I'm more
reptilian I don't understand what she's
trying to say to be honest they're being
facetious from the beginning no I get
that but I don't understand it's like oh
she's a poor baby no I'm telling
reptilian I'm like I don't I don't yeah
I don't know what Anderson's probably
saying that other people were saying oh
Nancy's a poor baby and then Nancy's
like hahaha no I'm not I'm a lizard that
I'm gonna go just take the election
that's my guess
okay but we need more context to
understand no we don't she's a lizard
and it's programming hold on hold on
Nancy Pelosi admits she is a reptilian
and that she's cold-blooded fact
Nancy Pelosi did say the quote I am more
reptilian and cold-blooded
yeah so uh if she said it's true right
well there you go she's a lizard it's a
revelation of the methods either lizard
or she's a liar where does The Reptilian
thing come from like why do people think
oh no this is actually a really good one
so David Ike who's one of the guys that
kind of founded this and it goes back to
like the Queen's Bloodlines I suppose we
can trace back to Muhammad I don't know
if you know this and Jesus supposedly so
it's like they think and it comes kind
of comes out of the Bible too there's
all this weird mix of like there's a
third of the Angels casted out of heaven
and these were like the Nephilim and
then the Angels slept with these Giants
and then we're kind of the
offspring of it so there's all this kind
of like Whimsical stuff or at some point
Angels made into the animals here and
that there might be Bloodlines like we
have and there might be Bloodlines where
these angels made of the animals and
they became human so you're saying that
the lizard people are Nephilim kind of
like they're in that Vibe have whatever
the Nephilim Vibe it kind of comes from
that time of this that's where a lot of
it comes the early origins of existence
I mean I'm not saying this is true but
that's what they say and there's there's
something weird though how the queen and
Prince Philip how they live for forever
I mean obviously they have the best
medical doctors but there's something
weird uh about blood I don't know about
Bloodlines I don't know I was just I was
just reading this list of the oldest
people and some like lady was 120 years
old and she was like a nobody in the
middle of nowhere yeah I'm saying some
people break the I mean some people live
a long time but it's just weird that
these billionaires live for a long time
well it's not I mean you can say it's
weird in that it's like not suspicious
it's weird that they do but it's obvious
what they're doing like don't they do
the the what are they called blood boys
blood boys blood boys uh there's um like
stem cell treatment stuff that people
I've heard stories of like these super
rich people who well there's that one
millionaire guy anti-asian guy yeah yeah
it was like having a son's blood
transfused into his body or whatever to
be younger and it's like yeah but you're
not gonna get much more longevity out of
these things anyways I mean you might
live a little longer because they have
access to better things but they're
really not increasing their longevity
significantly they don't and and part of
the transhumanist stuff is being able to
put your mind in a machine so you can
live forever they're obsessed with
living forever in longevity there's a
part of the The Reptilian Brain called
the basal ganglia that the uh the
reptilia of The Reptilian complex that
humans also have a basal ganglia so at
some point in our Evolution we were
active we were probably had only come
that far and I think what happened
there's this interesting Theory from
this book Ishmael that I got where oh
that book a long time ago yeah it's
pretty cool it's a talking gorilla yeah
we know all about it uh where after
something happened but a huge segment of
humanity went North they migrated Great
Migration a lot of people from the
equatorial maybe it was the great flood
something but they went North they could
no longer grow problems I got apology
right there is see the issue is we used
to believe in what was called out of
Africa Theory but I think it's been
debunked already what messages
like life recovered in Mesopotamian I
think they used to think that's where it
began but that's where it recovered
After the flood they went to like turkey
I think there's definitely a flood oh
yeah 13 12 800 years ago there's tons of
evidence like rock wall there's a place
right outside of Dallas it's called
Rockwall in its name because these guys
were digging you know whatever 100 years
ago and they found these huge walls that
were deep underground that make no sense
and if you can't dig it yeah because
Rockwell type in Rockwall Texas and
because they're so deep underground like
they think that it was maybe an Old Fort
so there is so and then what is it uh
um what is the tobekli uh yeah is is
what that didn't even the timeline
doesn't even make sense go back to A
Thousand Years yeah so that's where they
went that's where they recovered to
After the flood they went to go Beckley
Tepe or they built it after the flood
but it looked like it was like an
ancient Temple that they all all these
societies went and kind of congregated
at my theory is that these people that
went North after this cataclysm couldn't
grow crops so they had to hunt
constantly all they did was hunt they
hunt killed so they developed a
lizard-like behavior and then their skin
got lighter and lighter and then
eventually they came back south as these
marauding bloodthirsty conquistadors
murdering they colonizing Europe they
took over they eventually became and the
Romans and like so this like
bloodthirsty Behavior as opposed to like
eating crops the bloodthirsty behavior
is the lizard oh wow look at this
picture no joke a huge wall was buried
and so there is quite literally a wall
buried in Texas they can't even dig it
up it's so big wow that's really big
it's very big and they have no idea what
it's from there's no evidence they don't
even know what the hell so they just
named the city Rockwall so again look at
this photo here you can see they're
Excavating it and there's it's it's wall
man it's a big wall well I mean it's mud
flood bro you know about mud flood oh I
mean I'm just saying there's something
weird I mean we probably did have a
flood so wait wait for those that aren't
familiar that I'll probably be getting
around with the general idea which you
know obviously I find silly but uh there
are people who believe that there was a
massive ancient civilization a flood
happened wiping everybody out and mud
and sediment and everything shifted
around burying large components of this
ancient civilization and uh We've we've
begun to discover some of it there's a
the deeper conspiracy is that we've not
built these buildings we've discovered
them and that's why it is really weird
you'll see buildings in some cities
where there's clearly a door halfway in
the ground you've seen those right and
I'm like I don't know why they built
that building that way I don't think it
means that a mud flood happened and
buried the building it's probably more
likely that like Chicago they lifted the
city up things like that happen well
there is weird stuff too if you look at
all the old world's fairs they used to
build be able to build these beautiful
beautiful buildings with no power tools
with no modern technology and then they
would just destroy it you know shortly
thereafter or it got burnt out of fire
so I think there's a great fire Chicago
great fire San Francisco a lot of these
classic cities Tim they had huge fires
in around like the 20s or 30s so we
don't even know their own history so
there's something we I'll just say this
I'm a full-blown conspiracy there so you
don't need to be that but I think our
history is not the truth it's hold on
history is not true that's that's end of
story yeah end of story like look at
modern news today we know how it's
manipulated exactly and so we try our
best to piece together as much of
history as we can while knowing that
it's written by The Victors I just I
don't believe any of the religions
because of it I can't believe any of
those texts because it's all like less
credible than CNN what's interesting
though is there's so many different
religions that have very comparable
stories like so many different religions
have a story of the flood or Noah and
the arc so I find that fascinating
what if uh you know when the flood
happened it was actually you know what
when was when was the Sphinx under water
or whatever it was like we're on the
same period like 10 000 years ago 12 000
yeah years ago imagine what it was 12 12
000 BC you're saying uh they said 12 000
800 years ago it's like that's where
this whole go back to Texas all right
all this water damage oh interesting
yeah there's lots of erosion damage on
the side right so you have this ancient
civilization with wonderful technology
the Earth starts flooding and all the
wealthy powerful Elites are like we out
and they just leave earth when they're
gone and all the poor Yoko working class
rednecks get left behind where most die
and those who survive start to rebuild
and here we are today but I think the
real Elites told people they were gods
and like nephiliman they still had
ancient Tech they had hot air balloons
but that's an entirely different
conspiracy theory I'm just saying
there's a potential conspiracy theory or
I'm saying my conspiracy that I'm
bringing up right now is nothing to do
with any of that I'm just saying there's
an advanced civilization the ultra Rich
it wasn't Noah some humble guys like I'm
gonna build an arc it was a super it was
a billionaire social media Mogul who was
like building a Starship and then he did
and then when the flood happened they
left everyone else gets wiped out those
who survived the Water World start to
rebuild and here we are dude they used
to think the Sphinx was was like 3 500
years old well so and now they think
it's like 15 000 years old well by the
way we were off a little bit I think the
argument that they carved a different
head into it is it makes a lot of sense
yep one of the Pharaohs came to face the
lion yeah it used to be an actual cat or
or a dog Anubis or whatever and then
they cut the head down to really small
to be the Pharaoh instead yeah it was
like uh it was it because the Hat
doesn't fit the body size no it's all
receded man it was a beautiful lion I
bet carved out of the out of the
mountain you know I think the sad
reality reality is that we want to
believe these things because it gives us
mystery and lore and we can hope that
there's something crazy that might
happen but it's just not yeah we're
incapable of living without myth I was
thinking about going back to like the
800 a BC when the Romans were just
tribes and like 600 BC and if you could
go back to that period and teleport
around place to place time to time and
explore that that's why I want to live
is to be able to do that and I know that
with with like advanced technology I
think we're going to be able to simulate
that kind of experience where you're
actually there with the Romans talking
men are always thinking about the Roman
Empire I mean that's true well you might
you might wait that was a meme right
yeah it's a trend so ask a guy how often
do you think about the Roman Empire and
men are obsessed with the Roman Empire
rightfully so in my opinion but every
day because I follow stoic accounts well
I I wouldn't say every day but a couple
times a week at minimum dude that's
insane that's incredible to me water in
well because from the male perspective
women are basically just sitting around
all giggling with each other about their
hair right yeah and men are all talking
about like ooh ancient Rome you know the
row all roads lead to Rome because
that's so equally silly you know what I
mean yeah well it's funny it's a
serration it's funny Ian you said
something about Advanced Tech but I
think it's very easily provable I mean
you guys might argue with me on this I
think we're getting Dumber really fast
because if you look at just like the the
stone work that they did in New York
City not that long ago like the
Gargoyles and corners of buildings it's
amazing we can't even recreate that
today with all the technology we have we
can't make our girls what do you mean no
are you they can't recreate a lot of the
classic gargoyles and classic like uh
whatever stone work they've done oh come
on dude I'm dead
Google it I'm telling you there's like
the pyramids we can't build the pyramids
today they don't know how they build
experiments you can we can't Google if
we can build a pyramid
we cannot build the pyramids today
Google it Google it the way they build
this pyramids we cannot
I watched the video where a middle-aged
fat dude was was moving multi-ton Stones
he would he would dig through sound or
whatever though he would dig a hole
under uh under a portion of it and then
he would start rocking it until it
flipped itself over and he was like I
can move it and he started putting these
things together it was like Ancient
Aliens or whatever but we could tell the
pyramid we could not recreate have you
been to the luck sir according to
Wikipedia yes it is
concrete they don't even understand how
they built it now I don't know if they
use him create they don't know what they
use to build them back then
yeah that's what you're gonna say this
in real life too so yeah that's not the
bombs
we can't do it in the same way we cannot
do in the same way these guys are
smarter than us even though dude
Freemasons or whatever they're not we're
not as talented as we are today we used
to be smarter that's a ridiculous
Prospect I I watch that's a true
statement I watch hair I watched
somebody create the pyramid where they
used a stream of water to slice a
screwdriver in half I'm pretty sure we
can easily cut stone and stack it up no
the Burj Dubai you can't you can't just
like we can't go we can't check hey chat
fact check me we can't recreate the
pyramids look you're he's actually right
we can't do it the same way they did
because we can't enslave that many
people yeah we don't really know how
they did it yeah we had no idea yeah
they did it
I don't know how this means that we're
Dumber now like didn't they didn't the
Egyptians also think that the Earth is
flat yeah no they're right they never
did oh did they not it's not true uh it
was aristosthenes I believe who
correctly calculated the circumference
of the earth by comparing different
sticks and shadows but that actually
works for the local the Sun as well but
last night Katie Faust was saying or
actually we were just talking it came up
that a lot of our architectural genius
is being placed into video games now a
lot of male architecture mind space is
being put into video games and you're
building these these digital realities
so building gargoyles are being created
yeah free labor child labor on road oh
Roblox
I was just saying Tim a typical thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time